hey i'm kevin hi i'm katya and i'm jason
today we're going to be
drawing a stranger based only on their
voice
how do we feel about that i feel pretty
good about it
i'd feel better if i was drawing the
stranger from memory wait that doesn't
make any sense
a past life i could have known them
it was getting freaky i love how deep
we're getting so quickly yeah right
where do you know this person
let me go from here
[Music]
all right so here's how it works the
stranger can't see our screens we can't
see each other's screens so the only way
we know what to draw
is by what the stranger tells us and if
you're playing along at home
be sure to post your drawing and tag us
on twitter and instagram
at drop show you guys ready ready yeah
okay so let's welcome
our stranger for today stranger can you
introduce yourself hi
i'm vanessa hi hi vanessa
where are you joining us from i am from
boston massachusetts
but you don't have a boston accent and
not everyone from boston has a boston
accent
i fully expect to hear a boston accent
so
i have one when i get really angry but
i'm happy right now so
let's make her angry yeah how did you
come to be on the show today i watched
the show religiously i actually just
watched
the most recent episode i've been
following you guys on instagram
saw you guys were applying for a new
stranger
i applied and i got accepted and here i
am
congratulations thank you i'm really
excited to be here
so vanessa you have never met any of us
before so there's no way we know what
you look like right correct i've never
met any of you
all right you folks ready to uh get
drawn yes in true jason form i already
forgot your name
is it vanessa i'm sorry
i'm like stephanie can you oh wow it's
not stephanie
vanessa before we start could you tell
us what your pronouns are and also your
ethnicity
i go by she her and i am half portuguese
and half lebanese
very cool right down the middle
were you born and raised in boston or
outside boston i should say
i was um i am first generation american
what do you do in your free time i am
actually a professional body painter i
do that both as a job and as a
hobby wow that is so cool
that's cool how did you get into that i
went to school for theater
and i took a stage makeup course and it
kind of dived me into
i guess the art of makeup itself shortly
after college
i decided that i wanted to dive in more
and
i got a job at a professional theater as
a hair and makeup
person and i started learning
prosthetics
i started in my free time when i wasn't
working
at the theater to teach myself how to
pretty much body paint
past the face and the neck and then i
started to experiment on other people
and i've been doing it now for about
seven years
wow i love that you just kind of went
from like
one small part of your body and you just
like
transformed exactly i transformed i love
that caterpillar into a butterfly
wow i love that vanessa you sound very
chill are you are you generally a very
chill person
i am i'm a very chill person that's
actually what my friends would say
i always say oh it's just the gemini in
me and i feel like gemini's always get
a bad rep but we're pretty outgoing and
uh chill people
all right some of my best friends are
gemini's which is weird because i'm a
cancer but you know
that's a good thing is it yeah my
husband is a gemini
wonder you if i may ask i'm a cancer so
it's funny that kevin says that like
he's a cancer and a lot of his friends
are gemini's because i feel like i have
the same thing
i'm a mystery you're not gonna tell me
jason no
shame yes let's take bets on what he is
uh capricorn just from that
good work what is your favorite part of
your
face i would say my eyes um they are
almond shaped they're like traditional
what middle eastern
i guess features would be in middle
eastern women
i get lots of compliments on them
anytime someone meets me
they notice my eyes right away that's
very helpful thank you
i'm not gonna lie i'm struggling right
now friends
i've made some choices but i'm not
confident in them
i've always been struggling you know
like
what do you usually like paint like what
are the like the themes of things you
make
i've actually lately been doing a disney
theme so i've been doing like every
disney movie um
i just did a back to the future theme
because that's my favorite movie it's
one of mines too
i think it's the first choice see jason
we have something in common
it is a perfect trilogy there's no
trilogy better than the best
i don't know back to the future three is
pretty weak
it's pretty weak the doc gets to fall in
love
all right we can talk about this later
jake
what's the last thing you body painted
on yourself good
question i did a body painting piece on
toy story
a lot of movie themed body painting i
think it's what people like to see
whereas if i do a creation of my own i
find that people
aren't as impressed i don't know yeah
no not really not really yeah people
like fan art what's an original piece
that you were in love with
i did a piece where i did a bunch of
like different butterflies
because that's what vanessa means it's a
symbol that i just absolutely love
do you have a favorite color i do it's a
teal blue
blue love that okay it's the fad color
of the 90s
i'm a 90s baby all right all right i'm
digging what i have going so far i'm
pretty happy
i'm doing all right i moved on to inking
oh wow oh jason
you know how slow i am i like the form
of what i've made so far
okay do you have any piercings or
tattoos
i do i have a nose piercing i also have
my
ears pierced and i do have a lot of
tattoos
oh my goodness i think i have 10 tattoos
on my arms
oh wow okay so you take this whole like
drawing on your body thing very
seriously
to me it's not just a job that's why i
kind of do it in my free time as well
it's very relaxing it's what i do when
i'm upset
happy so if you had a bad day at work
you just come home and you just bust out
the paints and you just start
going to town like on your shoulders and
stuff yep
exactly exactly what you just said
in those movements too just throwing the
paint everywhere
just oh god i just need to relax you
guys
we should we should be at least halfway
through at this point
oh my god i'm i'm exactly moving into
inking now
i'm just writing her name and then i'm
gonna start drawing after
valerie i wrote it i think i spelled it
right
you said earlier that you have a nose
piercing yes
oh geez can you describe your nose
piercing to me yeah um i wear a hoop
and it's on my right nostril and i
usually wear a black hoop black coat
well that's easy so vanessa you were
telling us about the
butterfly body painting that you did
what was the general vibe like what was
the color scheme
it was monarch butterflies because
monarch butterflies are my absolute
favorite butterfly i have
one tattooed on my back okay and it was
a bunch of them i believe about four
or five of them on my chest and it was
a orange yellowy background and then on
my face i had
just neutral makeup other than the eyes
the eyes itself was like orange
yellow i always match my eyeshadow with
the actual body painting itself
and then i had a flower crown you got a
flower crown i did
oh boy okay all right i don't know how
much of that i can do but i'll try my
best
what are the tattoos on your arm of i
think you might be proud of one of them
oh is it back to the future related it
is
it's brand new i have a massive delorean
tattooed on my right arm
cool that's cool
i'm not going to draw that i'm so happy
i just got it it was an 11 hour session
wow and it's not done because we still
have to add lightning
the tattoo's not done without the
lightning that's how marty goes back to
the future from 1955 to 1985 so oh i'm
aware
i've seen the movies oh just making sure
i mean you were kind of saying you
didn't like the trilogy before so
i just didn't like the third one third
one yeah oh my god
of all the things to draw i'm drawing a
delorean and it's
stressing me out good i think it's
stressed out my tattoo artist too
you know what i'm just going to draw a
chushy train
so you said you wore a crown when you
did the monarch butterfly
uh body paint i did it's like a yellow
crown kind of like one of those 70s cute
little crowns that just goes around your
head
i love that is it like a little halo but
like right at your forehead level
yeah okay gotcha i don't know how close
you are jason but i'm just going to do
that detail and then i'm going to be
done
i'm ready when you are i'm just going to
keep touching it until you say it's done
all right wait don't use that
don't use that i'm gonna keep drawing
okay take two
i'm gonna keep drawing until you say
it's done
okay all right friends pens down
okay how do we think we did i feel
really good
i i really loved the the challenge of
drawing somebody
without knowing what they look like it
was really rewarding i think i did okay
does it look like her i don't think so
but i think i think it looks like the
spirit of her
i tried to capture a lot of the things
she talked about i liked what i drew
though so i'm pretty i'm pretty
comfortable with it i tried to capture
her
her chillness in attitude and pose and
then
i screwed it all up by trying to do some
uh body painting so
oh no we'll see i think they're all
going to come out amazing
oh yeah very sweet all right well let's
send them to each other
all right okay awesome
[Music]
oh my god these are beautiful you're
gonna see that you guys actually did an
amazing job
jason i absolutely love how you
incorporated paint
everywhere in my hair i actually have a
lot of hair so this is absolutely
breathtaking i also love how the paint
is just everywhere
you did great thank you kevin this
actually looks
like a lot like me this is insane i also
love how you incorporated one of my
favorite pieces
into this i know you were struggling a
little bit with the butterflies but i
think you did a breathtaking job
it's funny because this is a face i make
when i take photos
really yes i have this serious smirk
it's like you knew me
i figured from your voice yeah tatia i
like i'm just completely in awe this is
absolutely
gorgeous i feel like this belongs like
in a gallery it's
absolutely breathtaking i feel like it's
my soul put into
a piece and i have chills right now well
i think all three of you
have incorporated who i am as a person
both
inside and out perfectly okay wow wow
i'm so happy well you know what in that
case we don't need to see what you look
like we're good
okay all right great job
all right it's time for the big reveal
and if you're drawing along at home be
sure to pause here and finish your
drawing so you don't see what vanessa
looks like
everybody ready so ready all right
vanessa
when you're ready turn your camera on
all right i'm gonna count down
three
[Music]
i did yes i woke up early just to do it
oh
i'm gonna cry i feel so honored to see
this
thank you thank you so much this is this
is the quickest i've ever done a piece
by the way
it's been nine hours and i was like i
have four hours to do this
let's go how do you draw something so
detailed on yourself
on yourself yeah a lot of coffee uh
true time podcasts and patience
wow vanessa thank you so much for
joining us this was so much fun drawing
you for a better look at these drawings
your drawings and to find out how you
could possibly be
our next stranger be sure to follow us
on instagram and twitter
at draw show and we'll see you next time
i am a product of immigration
so my mother is from minnesota portugal
and my father is from beirut lebanon and
i am a self-taught body painter i can do
anything from a traditional
paintbrush to airbrushing anything that
your heart desires